travis barker rushed to the hospital
with wife courtney by his side what we
know about his condition i'm okay with
a bad day or a rough day with you than a
day without you
r kelly sentenced the dramatic moments
from court a stiff prison sentence that
sends a message to the world one no one
is above the law
dakota johnson's 50 shades confessions
i'm so proud of these projects and it
was really difficult for the first time
she describes mayhem behind the scenes i
know what i signed up for
inside brittany and sam's fairy tale
marriage she's amazing the husband thing
hasn't hit me yet just seeing the
sparkle in her eyes and more than anyone
she deserves this happy ending et's the
download starts right now
we begin with travis barker rushed to
the hospital in an ambulance in these
photos you can see the drummer on a
stretcher with his wife kourtney
kardashian by his side in a black
sweatsuit tmz was the first to report
that it all started with a trip to an la
area medical facility doctors there sent
him to the er and an e.t source says he
was diagnosed with pancreatitis the
possible cause a recent colonoscopy
according to the mayo clinic some
symptoms can include fever nausea and
our source says travis was sick with
intense pain in his abdomen as all this
was happening travis tweeted god save me
his daughter alabama asked for prayers
too and she also posted then deleted
this photo holding her dad's hand in the
hospital travis's health scare comes
just a month after he and courtney
exchanged vows in italy
i've never in my whole life dreamt of
getting married until travis and until
this relationship
we're really seeing your love story with
your soul mate on the news show we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah
and on the other side of the country was
travis's son landon he hit the stage
last night in new york with his dad's
longtime friend machine gun kelly
avril lavigne who has a track with mgk
on her latest album also shared the
stage at madison square garden she's
saying some of her throwback hits
but it's what went down at mgk's after
party that has social media talking
machine gun kelly posted this video
smashing a champagne flute on his head
he then performed a song with blood
dripping down his face he left the after
party with blood stains on his shirt you
can see him earlier in the night hand in
hand with his fiancee megan fox and some
other stars who celebrated include a-rod
and his lady love catherine padgett
avril's fiancee mod son and dixie
dimelio dixie's sister charlie was also
there hand in hand with travis's son
landon and things are heating up between
the two the source tells et the 18 year
olds are officially dating they have a
lot in common and are enjoying each
other's company charlie was previously
linked to fellow tick tock star little
huddy here's what she told et's kevin
frazier about that relationship two
years ago wait a minute
little huddy is here
it's great he's a really really sweet
boy
she's just been the sweet kid from the
go just a very
sweet like outgoing
bubbly human being like that's that's
that's charlie that's who she is the
question now will landon take any pda
notes from his dad
i've never seen my dad this happy before
i'm really happy for him i know it's
going to last really long and be an
amazing part of our lives
i just think people have trouble
understanding
how
two people can be so in love and
affectionate because they're miserable
all right moving on to r kelly sentenced
to 30 years behind bars in connection
with his racketeering and sex
trafficking case today's sentencing in a
new york federal court comes nine months
after the singer's conviction on nine
charges dating back decades prosecutors
called the singer a predator who used
his celebrity status to prey on young
women and children and that his
entourage of managers and aides helped
him carry out his crimes the allegations
that were levied against r kelly are
something that you don't hear every day
thankfully so so a stiff prison sentence
sends a message to the world one no one
is above the law now before his sentence
was handed down several of his victims
gave powerful impact statements
including angela who reportedly told
kelly with every addition of a new
victim you grew in wickedness we are no
longer the preyed upon individuals we
once were i pray that god reaches your
soul
this as newly unsealed court documents
are revealing disturbing new details
about kelly's past including physical
and sexual abuse he allegedly endured as
a child kelly's lawyers filed the letter
seeking leniency citing the singer's
traumatic past kelly who's still facing
trial in chicago on additional charges
never testified in his own defense but
did speak to gayle king back in 2019
denying all allegations against him
fighting for my life
y'all killing
i also thought a couple of times that
maybe we're witnessing a breakdown as
it's happening
during last year's trial kelly's accuser
testified about the sexual physical and
emotional abuse suffered at the hands of
kelly in 2019 victims also shared their
harrowing stories in the docu-series
surviving r kelly i didn't know how to
say no
all of a sudden
his tongue is in my mouth robert
you know what you did
you know the turmoil you brought into my
kid's life
you can deny all you want to
and for that
you can go to hell
all right heart pivoting now to some
much happier news fairy tales do come
true even for guys just asking britney
spears's new hubby sam asgari you shared
details from their magical wedding day
on gma you know it's just surreal man
it's uh it's been a minute it was way
overdue for us and we imagined this
thing being a fairy tale and it was and
we only had like 50 to 70 people we
wanted to just celebrate uh and that's
what we did and for the first time sam's
publicly thanking brittany for helping
his career he's getting ready to star in
the film hot seat and only e.t has this
exclusive sneak peek this has a bone to
pick with the city let's discuss asset
elimination i didn't really get noticed
until you know uh my wife gave me like
this amazing uh platform to work with so
i'm always appreciated of that but let's
not take away from the fact that i've
been working hard and i was already
acting just being in a relationship with
someone that has achieved so much
so many great things and uh at such a
young age
kind of gives me
the understanding and and and teaches me
so much for the little things i'm going
to achieve you know i think my
invitation was lost in the mail i'm too
weird how about they're big wedding but
somewhere around here right but paris
hilton was among the lucky few who did
attend the wedding i actually asked her
about that pick right here that you're
seeing that is taking over the internet
last night at an event for the hilton
group estates company what do you make
of the internet calling you gals you
selena drew madonna the avengers
so cute the amount of memes and things
that people have made they are so
creative what was the highlight of brits
wedding for you to see
everything just
her walking down the aisle and just
seeing this the sparkle in her eyes and
you know more than anyone she deserves
this happy ending you have been there
every step of the way for her it's
really incredible to see how amazing of
a friend you are
well i love her so much she's an angel
meanwhile angel katie holmes and
musician boyfriend bobby wooten are
going strong after a few months together
and get this he's got suri's seal of
approval a source tells e.t that bobby
and katie's daughter with tom cruise
who's now 16 years old have met and they
quote get along great adding that suri
has always been katie's number one
priority i gave my daughter a special
thanks she makes every day
great and awesome and and better and i
know myself more because of her
katie and bobby made their red carpet
debut in new york last month a source
previously telling e.t they're perfectly
matched adele and rich paul made it a
perfect and very glam date night at nba
star kevin love's black and white ball
inspired wedding over the weekend
it was just like a movie
it was just like a song
[Music]
kevin married sports illustrated model
kate bach at the new york public library
and an e.t source says adele and her
sports agent boyfriend were super cute
and attentive to one another love was in
the air and they were definitely feeling
it they even showed off some moves on
the dance floor with other celeb guests
including lebron james our source adds
there was a no phone's rule so everyone
just let loose and partied now while
adele and rich are living their best
lives a source is telling e.t that bill
hader and anna kendrick have broken up
the fact that they were even together
might actually surprise you since they
really kept it on the dl but a source
says they've been dating for quite a
while after co-starring in the disney
plus christmas movie noel in 2019 and as
recently as march a source told us they
were in love happy and in no rush to get
engaged bill was of course previously
married to film director maggie carey
and has three kids with her he also
dated rachel bilson who had some strong
words about splits on her podcast two
weeks ago i went through a really hard
breakup and it was during the pandemic
and i could not leave my house like i
could you know what i mean and so i had
nothing else to do but sit in it
and deal with it and feel it and harder
than childbirth even though like it hurt
like
like if you actually face it you can
come out of it and be like
okay
i'm moving on to joey king who's kicking
some royal butt in her new movie the
princess i was with the actress who
tells me she got some pointers from the
one and only brad pitt
what did you learn from brad about stunt
work
i mean brad is just like so agile and
impressive and gorgeous there's a lot to
learn from someone who can pull off all
of those at the same time we are right
on settle joey's definitely using those
skills she learned in her action-packed
fairy tale film out july 1st on hulu
joey is the princess fighting to save
her family in their kingdom turning the
damsel in distress narrative inside out
[Music]
what did training look like ahead of
these fight scenes training was pretty
um pretty intense i'd never done
something like this before
i did know for a fact that i wanted to
get to a point in my training process
where i was able to do most of my own
fighting most of my own stunts
85 to 90 of what you see on screen is
actually me i would be like sitting
there like just thera gunning my legs at
night like crying
next up for joey a netflix rom-com with
nicole kidman and zac efron your late
90s baby were you a huge zack man
growing up absolutely oh my god are you
kidding of course i was and he is i mean
i can't wait to work with him
between all these films girl when are
you wedding planning right
i'm just honestly like getting into the
thick of wedding planning but also i'm
just like so enjoying being engaged i'm
so happy for you all right is this a
little tease for the wedding dress are
you gonna go a little smaller can you
imagine oh my god no i hope not i mean i
do like the idea of dramatics but this
is just like i'm schvitzing under i'm
like chafing
you know who knows a thing or two about
celeb weddings selena gomez she was
actually a part of britney spears's girl
squad recently and there she is i had
the chance to catch up with selena and
her only murders in the building squad
on the season two premier red carpet
how would you guys fare as real-life
neighbors do you think these guys would
make good neighbors oh fantastic i don't
know i don't know but this wouldn't be
nice what if you have a lot of parties i
don't know i would i would
selena's fence going quiet down that's
true neither would be good i would
definitely have louder parties than
steve we are getting the hang of this
absolutely what are our plans for
selena's 30th birthday
really at home in bed by the time you
guys aren't throwing you just said you
throw a wild card well i'll just be
getting in when it starts yeah i hope it
happens by 10 a.m so i can celebrate it
season two is streaming now on hulu and
get this selena's fans will soon get to
celebrate her new music i'm actually
working on it right now it's just been a
little hectic with this but i'm i am in
the studio i'm excited
[Music]
givian just wanted you to hear his music
at the bet awards but a busted mic just
wouldn't let him shine here's a painful
little reminder
[Music]
so after the awards he tweeted that
b-e-t sabotaged his performance but the
poor guy was only joking folks don't
worry last night on jimmy fallon he
attempted to clean up the mess
right now
to whatever camera you want to would you
like to give you unexplain yourself oh
my is this the same mic i don't know if
i trust somebody
yes
i was joking
bt did not sabotage
supports me and would never purposely
alter my voice anyway um
i'm happy to be here
it was pretty cool uh dakota johnson on
the other hand has some beef with her
breakout role for the first time she's
pulling back the curtain on what she
calls mayhem behind the scenes of the
fifty shades franchise
so proud of these projects and it was
really difficult i had notes and the
producer said notes i felt brave enough
to do that role but i really needed
to feel safe in a profile for vanity
fair the actress says she hasn't been
able to talk about these experiences
until now christian green i'm anastasia
steele years after her breakout role
dakota confesses she quote signed up to
do a very different version of the film
we ended up making i emailed my manager
at the time i think i want to audition
for that i feel like it could be really
cool so what happened for dakota el
james who penned the best-selling book
series wielded a little too much
influence she tells the mag she had a
lot of creative control and she just
demanded certain things happen calling
it mayhem i was there
yeah every day despite the
behind-the-scenes drama dakota says e-l
was always kind to her i know what i
signed up for and looking back on the
experience now she has no regrets
there's been a lot of twists and turns
on the way and
and uh
and i'm so grateful for all of them
[Music]
on to a movie that's 50 shades of fun
it has been 10 years since mark wahlberg
teamed up with a teddy bear to bring the
laughs in ted
it was a blast because seth was actually
right off camera
[Music]
that's mark a decade ago on working with
seth macfarlane ted's writer director
and the voice behind the foul mouth
title character
and the bears moves well those are all
seth too
that was a conscious choice there's just
a piece of
humanity that you miss in that and you
can really only get it from the motion
capture technology i wanted to give mark
and i the freedom to improvise to make
things kind of casual
to record our voices
with the same mics bouncing off the same
walls and really make it feel like
the bear was there with him what i like
to do to her something i call a dirty
fuzzy ted became one of the highest
grossing r-rated comedies ever and
starts with a wish from mark's character
john to bring his childhood toy to life
just grab your thunder buddy and say
these magic words
you thunder is there anything
that scared you as a child that still
scares you today no i'm not affected by
like thunder or any of those things a
prison
prison scares you yeah
but ted who's a teddy ruxpin ripoff
threatens to ruin his adult relationship
with mila kunis baby please ask ted to
move out so we can move on with our
lives mark and mila were there on your
shortlist the entire time yes yeah yeah
absolutely you know he can do comedy
with the best of them all right brandy
heather channing brianna amber sabrina
melody dakota sierra bambi crystal
samantha autumn ruby taylor tara tammy
and yet it's somebody who still had to
be able to do
things like the fight scene with ted
and mila she and seth were old friends
from family guy i mattered shut up meg
you don't matter mila i had worked with
for 10 years
you don't see many women who look like
that who can also deliver a joke oh my
god i got some on my phone
the movie included surprise cameos from
the likes of ryan reynolds this is a
jared he's a guy who beat me up and uh
we're in love
huh
and another ted ted danson woody
harrelson
smallest i've ever seen on a man
word of mouth buzz led to a worldwide
box office hall near 550 million dollars
and a best original song nomination at
the
[Music]
i'm
oscars
i
was lucky enough to be able to bring
this bear to life in exactly the way
that i wanted i loved it actually one of
the best working experiences i've ever
had
one
two
three
yeah
[Music]
i love me some marky mark we need
another ted i would love a ted in real
life so i could get drunk and hang out
with the teddy bear that just sounds
like fun that all right on to another
major milestone
[Music]
a look back at jt's grammy-winning love
stoned 15 years later and how jersey
shore's angelina is dealing with her
public divorce there's a lot of stuff
that people don't really know that has
been going on for a long time between us
et's the download we'll be right back
[Music]
dc
oh
long before i know long before he blamed
his khakis for those dance moves last
week justin timberlake was embarking on
major solo success with the release of
his second studio album future sex love
sounds the fourth single from that
project was released 15 years ago
[Music]
the album as a whole went in four grammy
awards including best dance recording
for love stoned i think she knows jt
also won four mtv video music awards in
2007 including artist of the year now
ity spoke with him right after his
performance with timberland and nelly
furtado
[Music]
[Music]
your performance i mean it was electric
i'm asking you to rate yourself just oh
i give myself
um
a six and a half with a really good
personality that bumps it up to a seven
so here's a fun fact jt was just a few
months into his romance with jessica
biel at the time of that interview the
two married five years later in italy
and they've had two boys silas and
phineas since and they'll celebrate
their 15th wedding anniversary in
october we talk about can we talk about
your wife
yeah he looks incredible that's my
favorite topic
[Music]
once you find that person there's like a
baptism where you're like i can't go
back
you know what i mean i think i kind of
knew that he was my person sort of
early on i think before we got married
that's when i was like oh yeah this is
the person i want to i want to be in the
boat with
when we hit the rapids
[Music]
when are you guys going to do something
together
you know we talk about that a lot but we
do a lot of things together
well we know that justin said he wants
to have as many babies as possible
oh that's interesting i think it'd be
it'd be amazing to have a bigger family
now to the jersey shore star who had her
wedding and soon her divorce play out on
reality tv angelina pavarnik she's
opened up to et's rachel smith about
life after her tumultuous split
you are divorced how are you feeling um
it's been a struggle like mentally like
divorce is not an easy thing to go
through it's what had to happen and
there's a lot of stuff that people don't
really know that has been going on for a
long time between us you don't know what
was happening like literally my husband
was like well now he's my ex but there
was a lot of things he was doing
angelina says her two-year marriage to
chris was emotionally difficult for her
but the season premiere of jersey shore
family vacation dropped some new
revelations like angelina had a hookup
in mexico before her divorce on top of
that she sent the pics to the situation
i've been feeling alone in this marriage
for a long time chris left again he
moved out what about you and benny
might there be a possibility some sparks
there everybody wants it i'm like why
like do you want it no no no no no i
don't believe it we are friends but i
think he wants it more obviously that i
don't i mean i've been there done that
you know you never know though
they say you know never say never but i
don't think so well angelina's not
waiting around she even jetted off to
the canary islands to take part in
paramount plus's new reality competition
show all-star shore she joins other
reality stars like blake hortsman from
bachelor in paradise and giannina
gabelli from love is blind hoping to win
150 thousand dollars
basically we were getting lit together
all day every day but like we had
challenges we had to do challenges every
day what did you learn about yourself in
the process
that i'm not gonna be
taken for granted anymore by a man i'm
good right now alone and eventually i
will find my prince charming out there
well you gotta kiss a lot of tan
italians and muscle teeth before you
find your prince right i'm sure she's
gonna be great all right that's gonna do
it for us today tune in tomorrow for
another episode of et's the download bye
thought you're gonna say kiss a lot of
frogs
[Music]